we are making people be their own bosses
maybe yov which is the Omo exactly
spoken like a true mogul its next level
e t--'s Kevin Frazier was with
supermodel Tyra Banks on Wednesday where
she opened up about her growing Tyra
beauty Empire Tyra beauty is self-funded
I have people that come and join our
army of you detainers and then they're
making their money they're doing their
thing summer retire on their husband
some are just having a little extra
spending money but I really want to
empower people to like be the CEOs of
their lives
Tyrese Bo Erik asla was the photographer
on hand the 42 year old gushed over
working with her man he's so empowering
for me if I'm upset at work like he'll
be like you know what I should have been
stronger for you I should have told you
don't do that project he's very like
just he just wants to support me but
Tyra said just because he's behind the
camera doesn't mean he's safe from
tabloid rumors I don't have a famous guy
and so I thought because my guys thought
famous that I wouldn't have to do with
that but it still happens the couple
welcomed their first child a boy named
York in January it's heaven even just
last night I just picked him up and I
just like held him for 20 minutes like
3:00 in the morning no one I had to be
here bright-eyed for a photo shoot
blessing fellow
as for Tyra's long-running reality
series America's Next Top Model it was
resurrected by the h1 in February
Tyra will still be there behind the
scenes but she's handing over hosting
duties to singer Rita Ora it is not Tyra
I don't I don't want to fill your shoes
I want to make a lot to clean my own
shoes and so like I was like I got you
boo burger she's like I just want some
advice and some help and so I'm gonna
have a session with her in person I'm
like give her the ins and the outs and
you know say you know but make it you do
you she's gotta make it hers
you